just kidding news careful boys is a
brand just kidding news is the man of
smart people the people of just kidding
news careful boys they are very smart
just kidding news the number one forcast
in the
[Music]
world there was a bus driver here's a
couple details to this so let me finish
who lost her job after being caught
driving students while drinking white
claw oh was it a lady okay she was
actually a 60-year-old her name is Amal
Hannah okay and she was just pounding
down a white clawz pounding she's kind
of bored at her job I bet that happens a
lot she's been but she's driving though
a school bus driver for the past 15
years oh so she's professional she's
profession she just want to get a buzz
while you drive a little I believe in
drinking and driving if you've been
doing it for a long time and if you're
if yeah if you have a proven track
record yeah you're not like drunk and
driving I I think that when you get your
license you you could do one that is
like8 you drink like two drinks and if
you could still pass like the cone or
whatever you're allow then you're
allowed to drink and drive a little bit
but if you [__] up then yeah don't you
can't do it you're not good at drinking
and driving I think if you're texting
and driving and you get pulled over the
cop should be able to challenge you to a
drink and uh texting and driving
competition yeah competition I think
they should be able to tase you in a
nuts yeah cuz look there's some people
that are really bad at texting and
driving where they do like cuz it's it's
more of like a a 7 80 20 type of thing
where it's like 20% you look down but
80% you're looking up yeah but a lot of
people they do like 720 the opposite
way I could text and drive manual 0%
pretty [__] good I could text and
drive cuz one time one of my biggest
challenges I don't know why this
happened but when I was 16 I just got my
license I was texting a Driving Manual
and for some reason I think I was moving
in with my dad too so I had my big ass
dog Tyson sitting in my uh passenger
seat and every every [__] 30 seconds
I put your hand out here like holding
the shifter he would just go so every 30
seconds I was like oh [__] oh [__] and I
was still able to like like text and
[__] he was letting you text while
you were driving stick Shi my phone's
back then what was I doing T I was doing
something else oh yeah noia maybe yeah
oh alpha numeric I could text without
looking alpha numeric too well your dad
let you do that my dad your dog no my
dog was pressing on me dog oh your dog
Oh I thought it was your dad for I that
too 30 seconds my dog like oh [__] just
like press just press on my on my arm
shifts for you and I did I I made it
from stos to Elman safely yeah so even
if you're still alive even if it's like
the bus driver of your TA of school
that's okay to does he have the drink
drink and drive license yeah hases he
proven himself herself I mean yes yes
then yes cuz some people they're like
really smart right and then they do
alcohol and they're like they just
become normal intelligence but then some
people they're like normal intelligence
and they do alcohol and they just become
stupid as hell and there's people that
are stupid as hell and they do alcohol
and they're just like genius bro you're
really really dumb like because if I
don't drink really I'm more texting and
talking on the phone emailing thing but
if I drink I'm literally I'm so focused
true cuz you don't want to screw up I
don't want to [__] up true so I really
think that that is a thing cuz I feel
like drunk people they're so Focus is
that they drift into the next
Lane okay yeah yeah oh so continue with
the story what happened however in an
emotional interview with news2 Long
Island this devastated former driver
revealed that she was actually unaware
she was drinking an alcoholic beverage
cuz she's so drunk Seltzer oh she
thought it was like Sprite or something
she thought it was an ordinary fruit
flavored Seltzer that was non-alcoholic
I can see that she also said that due to
her
chemotherapy she's been left unable to
take and couldn't detect any alcohol no
she just felt better
afterwards she felt a little less
stressed felt relax she drinking one of
the cheaper alternatives yeah why are
you getting brand named white claw T the
[__] what about signature
selects she said pointing out the small
warning of alcohol content on the white
clock can she said that for people like
me that don't drink how are they going
to know that this is alcohol I think
it's a reading thing still read I think
it's a reading comprehension she says
I've been crying and crying I don't even
have any more tears it was just a
mistake it was a mistake I I believe her
because she's older and also she has the
chemo thing oh how old is she
60 well some some people deteriorate a
little faster no no she's a con artist
[__] this ly bit she also can't see
though the words she should be driving
that's a problem with seeing the road
maybe she she didn't drive anymore I
think she's given up a lot of excuses
yep I think she should die I think we
should drive her wonder how she was
advertised whiteclaw like how did she
discover that's what she wanted maybe
she wanted some sparkling soda you think
she was sponsored by
whiteclaw yeah because they're like
people are going to love that you can't
taste the
alcohol deal she can't even taste anyway
why did she just get like a perryer or
something yeah yeah she could have
grabbed literally anything anything it
would have tasted like anything maybe it
was a gift from like you know her
coworker maybe her white claw sponsor
her white call spor yeah she has three
cases nevertheless Hanna has been
terminated from her Ro her role there
her role there probably good idea uh a
Long Island base School company despite
her sincere explanation a company
spokesperson affirmed that this alleged
conduct is completely unacceptable and
the driver has been immediately removed
from service now here's the interesting
bit
what she's some within the community
have rallied behind her after her
emotional and heartwarming interview
that was taken as very CU they so
[__] weak bro heart strings baby
[__] weak weak ass people get console
easily and they started to Gund me for
her oh that's nice let's I want to give
her money you do I thought C on her you
want to give her
money I feel bad so because she's
undergoing chemotherapy but made an
honest mistake that cost her her job
people have donated thousands of dollars
to her that's pretty cool as of this she
lost like her and stuff she's no uh yeah
right there oh she didn't do it on
purpose look at her face really she got
one of those faces let's judge the face
I'm going to give her money cuz I just
talk some mad [__] called her a con
artist I think I should take it back by
putting money into her GoFundMe better
put your money in your mouth I will oh
she too young I thought she was 16 oh
damn she really does she is going
through chemo she ain't [__] around
dude did you did you think she was ly
you got to donate even more I did
too I was like oh [__] you see her face
that's a chemo face I was like sure Cho
What's the total on there as of now as
of now was
9,641 I gave her a compliment I said
she's too young she looks young yeah and
Bart called her a chemo face well so
Bart needs to give her way more money
than my mom told me one of my mom's best
friends had chemo growing up so I
recognize chemo face hard color a chemo
face that's a funnyest
accusation bar called her a chemo
face I mean clearly the evidence is
there he's not denying it and you're
calling me a bad guy I said what else
does she look like she looks too young I
said she looks too young she's not 60
she she might also be like a pillar of
the community yeah like we have a
crosswalk lady at uh at TA school and if
she's even just absent one day all the
parents like oh where is she where she
she's so loving she's like that lady
kids everyone Lov has she been a bus
driver for 15 years and she's got a
great track record let her get piss ass
drunk she's on chemo bro yeah you called
her a con
artist dude but that was an accident it
back now oh see yeah he changed his mind
Joe gr taking it back and I'm giving her
money on the go from me did you guys see
the body Camp footage of the teacher she
was uh she she got caught drinking at
school and she was getting arrested with
like the principal like the princi there
and oh is that the one she's all slurred
and [__] yeah they're like smell she was
like it's just juice it's just juice and
they're like smell the cup and she
smells it she's like it's just juice and
they're like it's smells like alcohol
juice and it arrested her for drinking
at school while teaching yeah no alcohol
on campus no alcohol on campus but then
that's wild that's a stupid move that's
crazy I feel like out of all the people
in the world though teachers should
drink yeah because PE like kids are
[__] annoying you got to loosen them
up yeah but a lot of teachers kids and
teachers should drink they I would
promote marijuana more than alcohol to
to teachers or about
mushrooms maybe micro you think they
should be high or that's something to do
afterwards post post to be like or
potentially like on their break cuz they
might come in and they like their their
niess and creative juices are just like
I don't think they're not like in their
cognitive cognitive functions aren't
like [__] up yeah you know what I mean
they might just be more like
engaged that helps students too like
when you come into class and your
teacher just in a good mood it feels so
nice all right as an unlicensed
psychologist I'm going to give her a
this teacher not the bus driver a
progression of meds throughout the day
so you start your morning with caffeine
coffee how many what' you say a th000
and hot
Bo I'm going to balance it out half a
pill of ecstasy okay what cuz you're the
caffeine cuz you're caffeined up and
then but you have empathy and you have
wow right how many milligrams of empathy
you're like this you're pick up every
kid I [__] love you I love you you
come from broken homes and we're going
to learn today about algebra and then
algebra too though right got a we turn
down the
lights here comes the
buildup no DJ no DJ pass and then all
right and at the end all right was good
cuz kids be having ADHD these days you
need a engaging teacher now you have to
grade the homework so let's give her
some Aderall cuz she don't want to grade
no [__] HK after 1,000 migs caffeine
and ecstasy she's going to come down you
give her a little you give her ader all
this all in one day of course every day
except the weekend Monday through Friday
so she needs Aderall cuz there's all
these shitty ass Chad gbd
essays
[__] so much there all these
assignments she has to go through so
annoying right how's she going to focus
ader all we're going to pump her up an
ad all then she's going to finish all
that [__] correcting the exams in 30
minutes she better be like 20 yeah no
water no water she can't be over 35 dude
she's going to get a [__] heart
attack juice for the Ecstasy then
there's more next of course and then no
we're going to give her some shrooms oh
what time what time do you give her shro
after the ader all what time is that
usually like 5:00 p.m. 500 p.m. okay she
gets the shrooms right so after the kids
leave at no this they can't be in campus
the shrooms has to be at home for dinner
yeah bar Mac dosing was [__] come to
your senses man I thought it was she was
still at school come on kids were're
dealing with I know after school program
come on man macro doing macro doing what
like you need to have an ego death every
day four kilos of mushrooms a day jumbo
do yeah because she needs to come up
with her lesson plan for tomorrow but at
the same time she has to go home and
there's normal life she needs to adjust
to right so then uh macro dosing is
going to help her with her love life
everything and at the end she needs to
sleep so we're going to give her
prescribe her an ounce of weed nice and
um she's going to smoke an ounce of weed
and then she's going to be [__] good
to like an ounce an ounce all right an e
how much is is a lot a [__] ton every
night is a lot how much is an ounce in a
week is a lot how much is it like a
regular blunt less than an eighth and
less than an eighth about less like a
half a gram or yeah like a half a like
eight of those yeah but she's a teacher
so that's why I'm prescribing her
anounce a little bit
more probably about 10 joint joints holy
sh she's foring on couch like this like
probably joint she probably still has
Aderall inner system at this point
exactly that's why she's going to need
about the macro dose of [__] shroom
all right so she God bro she's just is
this mandatory of course Friday for La
USD yes it is yeah but I guarantee you
after this she's going to sleep like a
baby she's going to balance out wake up
the next day do it again what about
daily DNT Mt is the only for the
weekends oh okay [__] when when she
needs to reflect back about her life how
much is teachers getting paid $30,000 a
year free drugs free drugs drugs that's
a lot that's a lot of money in drugs
that's a lot of money in drugs probably
three extra salary that's how much they
make here in in uh La dude that's crazy
30,000 yeah no I'm reducing their salary
oh you're oh they probably make about 30
to they probably make about 60 to reduc
salary they probably make about can you
Google it's been a long time since I saw
that's true what's new current L USD L
USD starting salary for teachers I think
it's
$60,000 um uh estimate is 52 to 73 okay
so $60,000 I was right I'm reducing it
by half cuz I'm giving her so much drugs
that she would have bought
anyway the thing is I don't think
teachers should do cocaine yeah I don't
think so either yeah oh that one you're
not no way no cocaine Zero Tolerance
[Music]
know